thank you guys so much for
uh joining us if it's your first time or
rejoining us if you
just took a little break from the winter
series we're excited to be back here for
the spring
horse grazing management series with
ndsu extension
my name is mary kina i'm the livestock
environmental management specialist at
the carrington research extension center
and you'll be hearing from me uh next
week and in a couple weeks
so today we have with us kevin sedevick
who's our range specialist
for ndsu extension he's also the
director of the central grasslands
research extension center
so kevin's going to go over horse
grazing management with us today
we also have rachel wald she's our
egg and natural resource extension agent
in mchenry county
and paige bruhmann who is our egg and
natural resource extension agent
in ward county and so those two are
going to supplement some of the things
that kevin's talking about
with some more boots on the ground kind
of action that you can take
and with that we will get rolling i'm
going to turn it over to kevin and
and we'll go ahead well thank you mary
and it is nice to be back
on this equine series um it's been a i
want to say it's been a nice day here at
central grasslands which were near
street or north dakota
because we had a quarter inch of rain
this morning and so that in itself is a
celebration of the day so
um we're gonna talk about grazing
management as it relates to horses and
the truth is it doesn't matter what
species you're grazing grazing
management
is a is an encompassing concept that
fits whether it's horses or cattle or
sheep or
or whatever for animals that the
difference is you know horses tend to
graze a little bit differently
um but we'll kind of cover some concepts
here and and we'll get into um some
different
topic areas as well some of the topics
we've covered today is obviously
a little bit on grazing management but
we'll also cover um some of the key
species that you may find
um on your on your pastures and you know
when it comes to horses we almost
typically see common types of grasses
in these horse pastures and so we'll
talk about some of those grasses to give
you a feel
for nutritional quality um palatability
and how they may fit into your grazing
program then we're going to hit some
topics on management that relates to
fertilizing
we'll hit some of the toxic plants um
just so you get a feel for if you have
these in your areas
to look for and what to do in case you
do have them
if you're looking to seed down a pasture
we'll talk about some seed mixes
where you can get that seed from and
then we'll
and on on this side of the story on on
on that that how to manage those
grasslands once you see them
all right so let's talk about types of
grasses
next and we'll and
we'll kind of cover these we talked a
little bit about fertilizing potential
toxic plants and where to plant these
grasses
next rachel so let me start with
probably the most common grass that we
see in a lot of our pastures in north
dakota
especially horse pastures is smooth
brome grass um some of you may actually
have metal grown grass in your mixes
um the brome grasses are my favorite
mixes to put in for horses because
horses
really like brown grass it stays
palatable for them much of the season
it's high quality and it's a nice grass
that you can use whether you're grazing
geldings
mares even even mares the falls on their
side and so it's commonly you'll see
these bastards
it's also a common grass that we'll see
in our ditches so if you're putting up
a ditch haze this also fits very well
next
and this just shows you a picture of of
a mature brome grass to your right and
so may
those of you you'll see these blowing in
in the wind in the ditches or in your
pastures it's
a very broad-headed plant um when it
gets to this phase it tends to be a
little less
less palatable and lower in quality and
so if you are putting up hay at these
stages
especially if you have a lactating mare
or you have some sugar horses that
you're actually using quite a bit
you may need to supplement some protein
with these feeds next
the other one we see common throughout
north dakota is kentucky bluegrass this
is true whether you're in north dakota
south dakota minnesota
whether it's was planted in a mix or
it's invaded your bromen grass fields
it's now become common in most of our
pastures it's a much lower growing plant
um but it is very palatable horses
really do like bluegrass
especially when it's green and lush and
in the immature stage
in the ecology business we tend to look
at this grass as an invader
because it tends to invade our native
prairies but in terms of horses this is
a really good feed for horses
um like brome grass when it becomes
mature it becomes a little less
palatable
and also loses the quality and so
protein tends to be
an issue when this grass starts to
mature out
next and the third one i'm going to talk
about
is crested wheatgrass and this is more
of a grass we see
in the western dakotas eastern montana
eastern wyoming
very common in horse pastures when i
call west river
um it it does well in the drier climates
so if you're in a precip zone
of 14 inches or less we tend to go with
the crested over the bromes
uh horses do like it when it's in the
immature stage
they do not like it when it's in the
stage we see in this picture here
starts to head out and so in this phase
we tend to see a lot of it put up for
hay
versus grazing and almost almost always
is used in cattle feed
and so we call it a wolf plant at this
stage and it's just because it has a
poor palatability for horses
next so the last one i have here
is is quack grass and i did lump um
intermediate wheatgrass in this mix
we'll call them the wheat grasses on the
average horses
um like wheatgrass but they don't really
you know prefer it over a brome grass or
over a bluegrass
most of our wheat grasses are typically
seen in hay mixes
especially if you do a crp mix or you're
doing a cd mix for horses you'll see the
intermediate wheatgrass and slender
wheatgrass put in this mix
where you have invaded pastures if you
have a bromograss field or a bluegrass
field
that's a little bit salty they tend to
get invaded with quackgrass which i have
in this picture here is quackgrass
horses absolutely love quackgrass in
this phase
and it's a very good high quality feed
and once it matures out it tends to
become less palatable
and you'll get you'll get some issues in
the next slider rachel
you'll see the picture here um of quack
where it can get a little bit coarse
so the last one we really have and
you'll see this more in in
the western half of the dakotas is
native pasture
when we get east most of our pastures
have been seeded for horses
so if you're in eastern dakota's
minnesota iowa
you almost always will see a seated
pasture in the western part of the state
so we'll see native pasture used for
horses it's a very good
high quality feed it provides year-round
grazing
because of the mixes of species in an
inner grass mix
and they're also very palatable they
tend to be a little bit lower in
production
compared to what i call an introduced or
improved species
like a metal brome or an intermediate
wheat grass but they tend to retain
quality better later in the season and
you can put these in about any different
soil type
and get your mixes to fit very well next
slide please
the nice thing about native range is it
is actually the most ecstatic
aesthetic value whenever you see the
pictures of horses
um you're riding a horse across
rangelands it's always a very
scenic area and i know one of our
speakers today paige has some beautiful
country up north of minot
where she gets a chance to ride and
she's actually on rangeland so it gives
you this aesthetic value that you can
use to enjoy your horse
on rangelands besides just a feed base
so next
so one of the management scenarios you
can do to improve the tonnage
of your forages on those pastures um is
fertilizing
and so whether you have a crested or a
brome field or even an orchard grass
field
if you're calling from iowa and you got
a timothy field they will always
be deficient of fertility once they get
to be about three to five years of age
and so we highly recommend fertilizing
these stands to one
keep them healthy and vigorous but to
also increase the tonnage
on these stands this is a picture of a
typical bluegrass
stand that's fertilized in the top
unfertilized in the bottom
and you can see there's quite a
difference there's not only greenness
but you'll see a difference in color
you'll also see a difference in quality
when you fertilize these fields
they tend to be higher in quality as
well next slide
and so this is actually a bromograss
field taken in south dakota
you can see the strips this test strip
on the right is fertilized
the control is not fertilized so you can
see how it grows much more aggressively
after a fertilizer program
you get a greener color and so on the
average we tend to produce about 50
percent more biomass
when you fertilize versus not fertilize
and if you haven't fertilized in
over five years or more you can tend to
double your production by the second
year of fertilizing so it's just a great
practice
to increase your your quality and
tonnage on that hate field around that
grazing field next
so when we look at fertilizing these are
some examples rod put fertilizer down
it's brome
crested wheatgrass intermediate wheat
grass timothy orchard grass
any pasture that's been seeded will not
have that
symbiotic relationship as we say with
the soil microbes and
lack what's called a fast nutrient salt
flow
do not fertilize native pastures native
pastures do not become
deficient of nitrogen because of the
microbial population with the native
pastures
if you fertilize native pastures they
will change and shift to
mainly in our country of bluegrass
pasture so only on these improved
pastures
uh so and so you can see where the
benefit will be in terms of production
and quality
next so
what what to fertilize with and you can
go next rachel's so
the most common fertilizer will use is
nitrogen
um if you go to a sales person and they
and you tell you want to buy fertilizer
for your pasture
they're going to try and sell you
nitrogen phosphorous
and potassium the only one that actually
adds
tonnage or production is nitrogen and so
it is the only one that i ever recommend
on domestic pastures you could add some
p and k
you won't be able to pay for it in terms
of tonnage but you might pay for it in
terms of
of different mineral contents within the
grasses but for me nitrogen's your
limiting factor
in the western half of the dakotas even
in montana wyoming
we do about 40 to 60 pounds per acre of
actual nitrogen
and after you do it back to back years
we do it every other year
in the eastern dakotas and in minnesota
and iowa we go about
60 to 80 pounds of nitrogen that's
actual nitrogen
um every for the first two years and
once you get into a program it's every
other year
next and so when do you fertilize
we're really reaching probably what i
call the end time of fertilizing
in the northern plains so late april to
mid may
is preferred and if you give if i gave
you the option i would tell you to
fertilize as early as possible
so you can do it during the cooler
climates and when the moisture is there
to give it that benefit
the most common fertilizer we use is
urea it is straight nitrogen so it's 46
nitrogen so 100 pounds of urea will have
46 pounds of nitrogen
and we typically will top dress this on
a pasture so the picture you'll see to
your right
just shows you a a spreader that's
spreading fertilizer and you can see the
white little
molecule or parts of that fertilizer on
the ground
and these need about a quarter inch of
moisture to get them to dissolve
and put into the soil once you're in the
soil
you start to see the activity from that
benefit next
um and it is important to talk about the
timing so if you do fertilize
now let's say we get in the mid mining
and fertilize and it's above 70 degrees
it will volatilize out so you want to
reduce
that impact of vocalization so try and
do it when it's cooler climates
thanks next so let's talk about weeds
and and i it's rarely i get a chance to
go into a horse pasture where there's
not some
weeds in those pastures and so one of
the more common ones you'll see
throughout the dakotas in minnesota
is horse sweet and this is an annual
weed that we'll see
and annuals tend to be a problem when
you over graze your pastures
next this is a common
i don't i didn't give you the flower
here but this is dandelion and we see
dandelion common in a lot of our horse
pastures
especially in the eastern half of the
dakotas in minnesota
on the average i don't worry about it
until it becomes a a visually
you know a quarter quarter of the stand
and then i'm going to look at a
herbicide treatment
to control the dandelions next
so this is a very young canada thistle
and i'll give the next picture too
rachel
um counter-thistle is common in a lot of
our horse pastures
another one you'll see is absent
wormwood whenever you see noxious weeds
like these coming in
that tells me that the pasture's
probably been a history of over grazing
so that niche is now there in the soil
profile to capture those seeds and to
get some invasion
from these weeds next i'm going to talk
about
toxic weeds and i'm going to focus
primarily on the trees today
next and so
i did a story on toxic toxicity in
horses on tree and trees about
three months ago and probably the most
common one we see are the maple trees
whether it's a box elder tree an actual
maple the leaves are toxic to horses
they have to consume a fair amount of it
to have issues
but it takes about three pounds of
ingestion per thousand pounds of weight
can be deadly in horses so if you do
have trees that border your fences
or border your pastures um it's
something you need to think about when
these trees start to when these leaves
start to fall off the leaves
or if you're getting too many in there
and other horses consuming it
on the average they will not eat many
leaves if there's plenty of grass
in those pastures you tend to see severe
anemia
depression and increased breathing with
maple toxicity
in my career i've seen two of this
happen where the horses actually died
from
maple tree toxicity next slide
and so another one we'll see especially
if you have uh trees within your area
like a tree grove
is choked cherries um we all like to go
get choked cherries and mix some chopped
cherry jam
but tocate choke cherries can be very
toxic to horses in the class
fact they're toxic to almost all classes
of livestock especially when the leaves
are stressed or wilted
the bark can be somewhat toxic but it's
primarily the leaves
and what you have here is cyanide
toxicity
which is very deadly to any uh animal as
well as humans
next slide so this is a picture of the
flowers
of chokecherry next and then
some of the symptoms you'll look at uh
with death before death usually occurs
is flared nostrils so you'll see them
they'll be breathing hard um almost like
if you're familiar with um
heaves and horses you'll see similar
that flaring of the nostrils
um with toxicity so they're labored in
breathing
lack of coordination and then trembling
and agitation so this is something to
look for
they need to get them off these if these
are problems
other toxic plants that we'll see that
are not palatable to horses
but you you'll hear incidents where
horses become
sick from these plants so horsetail uh
rachel will show horsetail first
um and then we'll look at
probably one that gets the most talk
about is locoweed
next well there's no pictures
so um local weed is one that uh get it
it's one of the
broad leaves that horses tend to you
have individuals that will pick it out
and they call it local weed because it
affects the nerve system
that's a tie attached to their eyes and
so everything looks big to them so they
tend to tend to run around
and they'll go to locals that's a common
one we'll see
milkweeds are very common in the
northern plains and you'll see horses
pick on the leaves on this one
but normally they won't eat it if you're
in the western dakotas
even in minnesota we have oak trees both
the acorns and the leaves can be toxic
late in the season if the grass is not
short you typically will not have a
problem
and then poison hemlock and ragworts are
also can be common
very deadly but oftentimes rarely ever
consumed
next and so we also have nitrate
accumulators
and these are basically plants that have
nitrates in them that have horses
consume it
can have an effect on nitric toxicity
levels
horses tend to not die from nitrate
toxicity
but they'll run a very high fever and
then you've got to gotta
get hold of the vet and take care of
that situation before they do diet i've
i've seen metrotucks have seen horses a
couple times
they almost always run a high fever um
death can follow but it is pretty rare
and so common plants uh that you'll see
is kosher
russian thistle in lamb's quarter these
are common in pastures that tend to be
overgrazed
and you can see the story i'm coming
with here keep your pastures healthy
and usually annuals and toxic plants are
not an issue
if you start to get areas of over
grazing these annuals will come in
and then you have the issues next
and so the last thing i want to talk
about and obviously will be here for
questions but is you're looking to seed
a new pasture or let's say you have a
pasture that's that's got some bare
ground in it and you want to overseed
that pasture
um there are some options you can look
at where do you get seed you know for me
in north dakota in particular i usually
call my local dealer i'll call into the
local town if i'm
living near new rockford i'll call my my
dealer in new rockford or i could call
anywhere you want
that sells seed and they'll find most of
these seeds for you there's also larger
seed companies
in the dakotas south dakota my example
here is just again cc but
there's a number of companies that have
access to buy seeds let's go to the next
slide
and we'll talk about what i call are my
favorite mixes for horses
um probably my my favorite grass
especially in north dakota
is is metal brome grass and especially
metal brome with a little bit of alfalfa
on that stand which then keeps the
nitrogen flowing in that plant
is a very nice quality feed for horses
whether you graze it or hate it
as we get in the south part of the state
into minnesota
you'll see orchard grass also commonly
used um
i don't recommend orchard grass in most
of north dakota because it winter kills
out
but if you're in south dakota or
minnesota especially inside the other
half
orchard grass can replace metal broom
the beauty of both those species
is they regrow really well so in a
grazing system where you rotate
you can get good grazing use get
regrowth and come back and graze that
plant
my second choice is the intermediate
wheat grasses or pubescent wheat grass
mixes
they're not quite as palatable as the
metal brome
but they do very well in our climate
even in their drier climates
um and they put up right when you get to
that boot stage
they also make really good hay the trick
is you got to get it up before you go to
seed
or the quota or the palatability really
drops and that's true if you're grazing
it as well
and the last one if you're in the
western dakotas and into montana you
know a crest your wheatgrass alfalfa mix
is a really good option for horses and i
do like alfalfa because
for the most part horses don't blow but
if you had about 10 to 20 percent of the
stand alfalfa
and like getting the other animals they
almost always pick the grass over the
alfalfa when they're grazing
it gives you a way to keep nitrogen
flowing in that system and so it's a
nice mix
for horses next
and so the best time to see these these
mixes is is right now
if you need to do any kind of seating um
early april to late may
is that window of opportunity i like to
put my my seat in
by right about now or end of april early
may
i know this year's been pretty dry so
timing will be more critical in hitting
the rains when you put it in
so you can time that with with the
future rain events
to do that the second best time period
is a dormant seating or we call it
dormant seating
and that's mid-october to early november
you basically want to seed it
but you don't want it to germinate in
the fall and you want to germinate the
following spring that's why it's called
a dormant seeding
these are very successful and almost as
good as the
as the spring seatings um it's just a
matter when you can get it in
next and so um
let's talk about this over seeding and
and we i even i've done this in my
pastures
as i've overseeded when i get my sta my
pastures are about 25
years of age so i'm seeing some age
issue with my
grasses and so i'll actually go in there
on the bare spots
and and broadcast it in and then i'll
drag it in um if you get drilled
it's even better but it's an option you
can do to kind of
get more production out of it if over
grazing is your primary reason
you're going to have to still drop back
on that grazing pressure especially if
you want to seed it
and get some growth before those before
you put the horses in
and we typically need about you know i
would say about four months of growth
for that graph
growth for that grass get enough root
structure so it can withstand the
grazing pressure
and depending on your pastures i like to
see that like species
so if you have a bromograss field seed
with brown if you have a crested field
seed with crested you don't want to see
the brome in the crested
because the horses are going to always
pick the brome and the crest it'll get
wolfie on you so drill so seed what's in
that mix
and the preferred technique is drilling
it in versus broadcasting if you do have
access to broadcast and you can drag it
in
that is another option especially when
it comes to overseeding
next slide um that's the end of my talk
and so i think i think we're going to
turn it over to i believe it's
not sure it's rachel or page but i'll be
on for the rest of the
of the session and we take any questions
at the end thanks kevin
uh a lot of what kevin talked about
actually
coincides with the grading strategies
and grazing ideas
um so with the season that we have this
year we're actually
not um you know we're looking more into
the the limiting term out time or
rotational grazing instead of continuous
grazing because of the fact that we're
so short on moisture
that that the the ability of those
blocks or those pastures to come back
after after some pretty hard continuous
grazing is going to be a lot harder
because we don't have
the moisture to bring back those grasses
um
we also noticed just a slight discussion
on this because we're going to talk
about drought next week but we did also
notice that there are some delay
in these grasses as well um so we
really want to watch that before we turn
on to pasture and again we'll
we'll talk more on that next week but
this is a good
um picture to show so that you
you know you have a sacrifice area with
water or shelter
a place that you can feed um your grains
or supplements or dry hay
and then hopefully be able to rotate
them through the pastures so that you
can't
you're able to keep pressure off of one
area more than the other
um so this is just kind of a good idea
for grazing strategy so again that
rotational grazing meaning
um that you'll go from pasture one to
pasture two to pasture three to pasture
four throughout the season
or limiting turnout time um to your
critters maybe
uh keeping them in at night after
they've they've had
a little bit of supplemental grain or or
possibly a little bit extra hay
to make sure that they're not putting
too much pressure on that pasture
so with the rotational grazing uh you
want to take into
thought the number of paddocks that you
have available to you
um and how many days with
how many horses you're going to be
putting in there so those are some
things i
we really want you to look at especially
with on the situation that we're in this
year
grass is going to be a hot commodity
this year so if you're able or you have
any
or you're able to graze um this is one
thing to really watch to make sure that
you do not over graze those
those paddocks or or different locks
that you have set up for your horses
this is just kind of a rule of thumb so
if you have two paddocks
um in the spring you turn out to
one that's that's appropriately um
the appropriate height for grazing then
you're looking at maybe
14 days of grazing with 14 days of rest
so and then it changes throughout the
summer because
in the spring you're going to have your
cool season grasses that are that are
coming up and that's what
your horses are going to graze on in the
summer you're getting your warm seasons
or your later spring a year later cool
into your warm season grasses and then
in the fall it is your warm season
grasses
too so making sure that these are able
to come back for fall grazing or
you know keeping that pasture available
so that fall grazing is a possibility
for you
so it all just depends on how many how
many pastures you have available
how many horses are going to be going
into that so this is all
part of what what you'll need to watch
for rotational grazing this summer
i'm gonna just lightly touch on some of
the weed management for pastures
uh kevin did talk about you know how a
lot of
a lot of pastures that are overgrazed
you're gonna see more weeds in them
and this is this is something that that
is really needs to be watched as well as
is weed management is basically whole
pasture management
um so starting with whole pasture
management is going to help with
any weeds that you get um and then
there's
there's several ways to control them the
three main ways that we're going to talk
about is
is cultural chemical or mechanical
um so there's not not a ton of
cultural methods but um chemical or
spraying is is one of them and then
mechanical
um is the other so mowing them down
instead of spraying them could be an
option for you especially if you have
smaller pastures or
maybe don't want to spray because you're
not
able to if they're the horses are in
there we don't recommend spraying while
any animals are in there
and then also following the label on any
chemical that you utilize
on the first thing you want to do to
make sure that you get uh proper control
of any weeds is to id those weeds so
knowing what you're you're up against
knowing what you're handling
is going to help and it go a long way
when you're talking about possibly
either chemical control or mechanical
control because
then you know you know when the best
time to mow is when the seed head comes
um when the best time to spray is and
when you're going to get the best
control for it
so those are the things that we really
want um
want to look at because when you have
kind of an overall control
or overall
management of your pasture your grass is
going to grow well enough to out-compete
those weeds
so making sure that you're taking care
of the weeds that you have
so that your grass can you know help you
with the control of those weeds in the
future
so making sure you know weed management
starts with pasture management
and then kevin also talked about uh
fertilizing your pastures we did want to
mention a little bit there is a
possibility of
you know you can do some soil testing on
that posture to see
how much nitrogen you may want to put
down um
and then he also mentioned you know you
don't usually
want to put down any phosphorus for
potassium but when you're doing soil
testing
we then can see how much is there which
is good like he said for
the nutrients in the plant or the the
minerals in the plant
so that's good to know as well um ph
and organic matter is also good to know
especially if you're needing to over
seed on anything you're able to know
kind of what seeds would be able to be
put down
with the ph levels that you have there
usually
when you soil test you go to a depth of
six inches
um and you don't want to just test in
one spot you wanna
you wanna test the whole field and you
can collect samples kind of in a zigzag
pattern
using a spade um and adding you know six
inches of dirt into the buck
into a bucket mixing it all up and then
putting it into a bag
um like there is on the right hand side
i do have one right here too
um and we do send that off to the ndsu
soils lab
so that's that's normally what you get
back is the nitrogen phosphorus
potassium ph and organic matter
um usually you can can do soil testing
about every three years
so it's not an every year sort of thing
um and
kevin had mentioned too you know you're
not gonna fertilize every year
once you get into it it's gonna be
either every other year or every two
years
or every every third year sorry um so
you just want to make sure that that's
kind of
kind of how you're going if you do have
um different
areas of a pasture so a high area and
maybe a low area
i would suggest soil sampling those
separately so your low area and your
high area
would be two different samples so you'd
end up putting in
um two different areas so that you know
you know kind of what's going into both
of those
and next i'm going to actually turn it
over to paige
all right so let's talk about when to
initiate and cease grazing
a lot of people decide when to turn out
just based on the calendar
and that's not the best method as it's
going to vary year to year
depending upon the weather conditions
and then also what part of the state
you're at
and what species you have in your
pasture one of the recommended ways to
determine
when to start grazing is by leaf growth
stage it's the most accurate for most of
our species
and and the majority of them you know as
a general rule of thumb we're going to
say three to three and a half lease
stages when you want to start
so this picture on the left we have one
full leaf two
full leaf three full leaves so this
picture on the left is a three leaf
stage
the one on the right is at three and a
half leaves three full leaves and then
this
fourth one is just about halfway out so
that would be the recommendation that
you can use in your own pastures
some people really like to go by height
of the pasture as well and that doesn't
consider species differences
so there are some recommendations that
you'll find out there from different
universities and grazing management
publications that'll say
you know start when grazing when the
grass is six to eight inches tall
if you're in an area where you have a
majority of grass species in your
pasture that don't ever get that tall
even in a high moisture year that's not
going to work for you
so you really kind of need to know what
what species you're dealing with
but if you're going by the the height
method and that's a lot of our cool
season grasses that follow
those recommendations in some
publications you'll want to stop when
the majority of your grasses are about
four inches tall
that's also an issue too when we hear
people say
take half and leave half and that is a
good recommendation but we want to think
of that by the volume of the plant or
the weight of the plant
and not just the height because again
some of our grass species
don't get very tall but they may have a
lot of leaves at the base of the plant
so the idea is is that you're taking
half of the plant and leaving half
we do have more information on that in
another publication
um so the detriments of grazing too
early is that you're gonna
reduce plant bigger it reduces the
amount of plant leaf surface or leaf
tissue
area that's needed for photosynthesis
and growth so you're gonna end up with
weaker plants
thinner stands lower total forage
production and increased
risk of those disease pressures or weed
pressure along with disease and
and potentially some insects so that all
comes back to what rachel's talking
about for grazing management
grazing too early and overgrazing a
result in these issues
and it can take several years to regain
productivity
on the flip side of this you can also
graze too late kevin mentioned
especially on plants that are
unpalatable once they head out and reach
maturity like crested wheatgrass
if you wait until the plant is headed
out the horses aren't going to eat them
and they're going to end up
wasting that grass
so here's a visual for over grazing when
we say take half and leave
half let's look at what that could mean
so if we remove
50 percent of the volume of the leaf the
percent of growth
growth stoppage is two to four percent
so just a small amount
but as we increase removing seventy
percent
of the volume of the leaves you re you
stop or reduce that root growth by
almost eighty percent if we remove
eighty percent of the leaf volume
you completely stop root growth
okay so that's some of the underground
things so sometimes we just look at
what's growing
above ground and what's happening with
the forage production that way
we have to keep in mind that the root
growth is also very important for your
plant figure
next thing we're going to talk about is
transitioning your horses to spring
grasses we have an issue
with some horses and sometimes we forget
that this can be an issue when they go
from
eating a dry forage that is maybe a
little bit
lower in non-structural carburete
carbohydrate production
and we suddenly turn them out onto a
lush
green grass pasture like we have in the
picture here
that sudden change can cause pine gut
disruption meaning that
normally the nutrients that are absorbed
in the small intestine
get bypassed into the cecum and can
cause some issues
in horses primarily they'll start with
symptoms that are similar to colic maybe
some diarrhea and gas
and if we don't manage that or back them
off of this
new change in diet and higher levels of
our non-structural carbohydrates it can
continue to cause issues
drop the ph and result in some laminitis
problems
so the key thing to remember here is to
adapt your horses to spring grass
slowly so say right now if they're on a
full hay diet
in a dry lot while you're letting your
pastures grow and reach the appropriate
stage before you turn them out
when the grass is ready to graze start
by letting them graze that
15 to 30 minutes a day at a time and
increase that each day
until they're grazing and out on grass
for more than four hours a day
at that time you're usually safe to
consider or safe to let them
graze the entire time or stay out on
pasture the entire time
that allows the microbes to adapt
you want to monitor your horses closely
if they have any of the symptoms that we
talked about
and remove them from grass and certainly
consult with your veterinarian if the
symptoms are severe
here's a couple methods for managing
higher risk horses so our
are insulin resistant horses horses that
have been diagnosed with cushing's or
horses that are obese you can use
grazing muzzles
try to avoid grazing in sunny afternoons
you can consider turning them
out just overnight after they've been
adapted to that spring
grass even at the lowest non-structural
carbohydrate levels in the early morning
hours
can still exceed the recommended intake
for some of these at-risk courses
so again you want to work with your
veterinarian to come up with a
good strategy and realize that all
horses are at
risk but some of our horses are even
more at risk
so that's all i have for you today i'm
going to go ahead and turn the floor
back over to mary and she's going to
finish out the webinar
okay so um are there questions this is
the time when you guys can unmute
and um ask questions and we can actually
rachel if you want to send it back to
just the gallery view
then people can go ahead and unmute and
ask some questions we did have some
stuff rolling through the chat
so while you're thinking your question
um veronica had
asked about horses being treated after
eating
red maple tree or other toxic plants and
kevin just went ahead and answered that
if if that is a potential to call your
vet
they can possibly treat with activated
charcoal or mineral via stomach tube
and so calling the vet in a case of
emergency is always good
other thoughts or questions
okay mindy says can we fertilize with
manure
that is one or two years old
um if so when's the best time to do that
so i
am going to see what kevin has to say
about this just from a grass standpoint
um even though i'm the manure person so
i'm gonna let kevin
um take a shot at this and then i will
follow up
well i'll say you know spreading manure
on tam grass pastures
is a is a technique to add fertility
and and mary will tell the details on
this but it does add nitrogen into the
profile
as well as p and k and so it is one of
those that you can use and you can
you can really spread fertilizer any any
time but the best time and i'll let mary
cover that
is you do get a benefit from that manure
now mary can tell you when and how much
so um yeah we we like to
uh soil sample um to tell us the how
much
and the when i i would just say so kevin
had talked about you know using urea or
using a
nitrogen um that's gonna be really
readily available
um ner is less readily available it
takes a little more time especially a
horsepower
horsepower is very neutral in how
the the nutrients um are mineralized
so it's not so there's like a liquid
manure
would have more of the properties of uh
right now
nitrogen whereas horsemanner um it just
takes a little more time
and so that is i i wouldn't recommend it
if you're going to say we want to spread
it right now and have
beautiful green pastures um probably
going to go with kevin's recommendations
from earlier
but if you're thinking i have all this
manure and i want to spread it i
composted it on spread i want to spread
it raw
absolutely spread it it is for fertility
just um keeping in mind when you're
going to do that
and so probably i would recommend doing
it in the fall so it has time to
mineralize and then by spring
we should see some benefits from that so
a great question up there and i don't
know the answer to this but maybe
page does obviously horse manure can
carry parasites
um is there a time period when that when
you get less live parasites in terms of
age of manure well this one back at mary
too and making sure that if you're
applying manure that it's correctly
composted
and heated to the appropriate levels to
interrupt the life cycle of those
parasites
what was the follow-up question i'm
sorry
i don't know if you had any specifics on
um
you know what temperature the pile needs
to reach in order to make sure that
we're killing those
parasites through all of its life stages
okay
yep so we want it between 130 and 150 um
is a really good uh good place to have
that so
we're gonna be killing weed seeds
pathogens um
all of that stuff between those
temperatures we're still having some
composting action happen
under that 1 30 um i mean if you stick
your hand in there you're like wow this
is pretty warm so there is some action
happening but if you want that actual
pathogen and weed seed kill we're going
to want to make sure that we
um are under the are between the 130 and
150.
we don't necessarily want to go over
that either uh because that's where we
then
kind of kill everything we just killed
the entire process uh and so that's more
of what happens in stockpiling we have
one really great heat cycle
and then it stops so that is
what i say there and
it looks like brooks has a question are
there any forages that are better for a
horse
um that have foundered
from a grass standpoint i think this is
hard uh hard to manage
um because the nutritional values of
grasses change so quickly throughout the
grazing
season that i believe the recommendation
for
horses that have foundered or at high
risk for foundering again is to manage
their diet a little bit more closely
with forages that have been tested um
so you know i would definitely work with
the vet because it's going to depend on
the risk level of that particular horse
you do see some horses that have just a
mild wrist uh foundering or mild
laminated case
that you know they can graze for a short
period of time with a grazing muzzle
and um they're fulfilling their
nutritional needs with a balanced
dry forage on the other hours of the day
so it's going to really be an
individualized case
and if anybody's wondering why rachel uh
is sharing this again i just asked her
to this is a new
uh reporting that we have to do and so
if you want to scan that qr code or i
put the link in the chat if you want to
do that you're more than welcome to
uh just some demographics age uh race
ethnicity
questions um are there other questions
relating to and so um miner management
we're gonna go into
just a little bit next week we're gonna
touch on and then we're gonna have an
entire
hour of it uh in two weeks and so
um certainly if you have questions and
you didn't put them in the registration
when you registered
you can register again and type it in or
you can just send it to me
when i send you the the link for where
we're putting
um this recording you can just send a
question back if you have something
specific you'd really like me to cover
in the mineral talk
and next week we're focusing on drought
management which is a
very pertinent and timely topic for the
entire state of north dakota this year
yes and so that's where we'll learn more
about um
feeding during the drought and grazing
during the drought
a little bit of dry lotting and winter
management during drought and so
all things that you're wondering about
and again if you have questions specific
to that
that you may not have answered or asked
you can
send those to me too
okay i think with that uh we will be
done for the day
so thanks guys for participating and
we'll see you next week